okay I have to ask you a Super Bowl just
is in a few days who do you thinks gonna
win mm-hmm well according to next-gen
stats from Xbox they'd say that Carolina
is the faster team explain that what
does that mean next-gen steps I heard of
those stats work well they're able to
calculate based upon speed and the
amount of distance travel throughout the
course of the game just kind of the
effectiveness of the team and so they'd
say Carolina is the faster team and
therefore they've predicted them to win
and they've guessed the winners 67% of
the time this year
Oh which is pretty impressive but I'd
say here's think I played against
Carolina twice have not played against
Denver here in a few years
both teams have phenomenal defenses
Carolina had one of the best offenses in
league with one of the most dynamic
quarterbacks on cam but then there's the
Peyton Manning factor on the other side
I think that I think that if they played
ten times so I think Carolina wins eight
but is this the time where Denver wins
and you know if this is Peyton's last
rodeo then I'm sure we're gonna see his
best okay so you've got money in your
pocket who are you putting it down on
Panthers it's a I'm not I'm not gonna
make a prediction but I'd say you're
dealing with experience in the Broncos
versus just you know raw talent and you
know on the other side but I don't know
yeah all right
very well done it's election season
really well done
have you thought about public off well I
think they're both great and I wish them
but I do have to ask you thank you it's
gonna be a tie and they're all gonna hug
at the end and I love America no I
actually I had to ask you this because
you brought up Microsoft and it was
something that a lot of people were
talking about the Microsoft tablet was
part of the playoff game I was watching
a Patriots fan sorry
grew up in Boston nothing I can do about
that and I'm watching
get out of my show anyway
I don't care that much anyway I'm very
fickle but they didn't work during the
championship game and it's people were
talking about it it was a little bit
strange as they kept saying the Patriots
in complaining that their tablets aren't
working and then they'd go to commercial
and then they'd be a commercial for a
Microsoft tablet which felt a little
strange what was going on there
well actually the league League came out
and said that it was a network issue and
it had nothing to do with the surface
actually my experience with the surface
tablets on the sideline has been
phenomenal over the last few years and
that's what we use to basically look at
the you know pictures of the defense and
the place from the previous series and
that is so much more efficient than what
it used to be used to be where they
print out play pictures and past
pictures and imagine a 15 play Drive and
all of a sudden you're getting handed
four pictures per drive a 60 page
booklet - right through invite you're
trying to reference a what was play 10
what were they doing at and now it's
right there on the surface boom hit the
button I can zoom in I can you know
communicate with my guys and then get
back on the field so much faster so
real-time the efficiency of the surface
has been phenomenal and so you're not
looking at porn contrary to popular
notice that guys are on their tablets
all the time I'm like well I know what
I'd be doing
laser focus no I think you would have to
be releasing focus but you just it
boggles the mind how it's going to
change the game because maybe five 10
years from now when people go to the
sidelines the technology's going to be
such that they're looking at like a hot
3d hologram of what just hololens
Microsoft has that come in which is very
well could be I think the next step is
gonna be video where you're actually
looking at live video from the series
before which they've experimented with
in the Pro Bowl we actually did it last
year and the difference between what
you're able to communicate there versus
just the still pictures is such a big
difference I remember pulling Antonio
Brown aside last year from the Pro Bowl
because I had seen on the video he went
you know behind the defender instead of
in front of the defender on a certain
path plane and said hey if we get back
to this make sure you cross this guy's
face and we could get a big play and
sure enough I think two series later
when it's going to touch down on that
exact play because I was able to see it
we were able to communicate it so that
that certainly provides a great
advantage and then you watch porn okay
I just had to get that out